من جديد تعود مصر لمحاوله الوساطه في
السودان بمباركه رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي التقى
رئيس المخابرات العامه المصريه في الخرطوم
مبادره تاتي بعد غياب المصريه عن جهود
التسويه السياسيه في السودان لكن يعتمد
نجاحها على مدى تقبل القوى السياسيه
السودانيه للدوري المصري طبعا في قوه
مقاومه هتكون من القوى السياسيه
لمثل هذا التوجه المصري لكن انا اظن في
تقدير الشخصي انه في ضروره موضوعيه
للتوافق السوداني وان السودانيين يضربون
ذلك لان في في ادوار للدوله معطله في
وظائف معطله في تهديدات امنيه متصاعده في
مشاكل اقتصاديه متصاعده بلد محتاجه حكومه
محتاجه سلطه تنفيذيه محتاجه سلطه امنيه
متوافق عليها لا تمارس عنفا في الشارع
وتمارس دورا في الحمايه
للوصول الى حاله من التوافق بين القوى
السياسيه سودانيه تقابله حاجه ناسه للحفاظ
على مقومات الدوله السودانيه وهو ما يدركه
الجميع ولكن هل تتوفر لديهم هذه الاراده
لنا يعقوب تقف جنوب مجرى هذا النهر وربما
يكون لديها اجابه اذا كما قال الزميل تامر
فعوضه مصر الى الواجهه السياسيه في
السودان تاتي هذه المره عبر مبادره يحملها
مدير المخابرات المصري لحل الازمه بين
الاطراف السودانيه تقول مصادر العربيه ان
المبادره تستهدف ثلاث كتل الرئيسيه وجمعهم
في لقاء لحل لخلافاتهم على ان يكون هذا
الحل سودانيا خالصا
مدير المخابرات المصريه عباس كامل تلقى
ضوء اخضر من رئيس مجلس السياده لقياده
المبادره ليشرع بعد ساعتين في لقاء الكتله
الديمقراطيه والقوه الوطنيه والمجلس
المركزي ورغم ترحيبه جميع الاطراف الا ان
الاخيره جدد طلبه المعلن لعباس كامل بان
يتم اشراق قوه معينه وليس جميع الاحزاب
السياسيه
ان تدخل الحركات المسلحه خاصه
حركه مناوي وحركه العدل والمساواه الى هذا
الاتفاق بجانب ادخال الحزب الاتحاد
بتكون همم اضافه رقم كبير جدا الاتفاق على
الايطالي
ساعات قليله واجتماعات محدوده لمدير
المخابرات المصريه مع الاحزاب السياسيه في
الخرطوم والتي دخل بعضها اليوم في
اجتماعات لبحث فرص نجاح الرؤيه المصريه
وتسريع ايقاع المشهد المتباطئ في السودان
ليطل سؤال بلا جواب واضح كيف سينسق
القائمون على المبادره الجديده مع الوسطاء
الذين اوصلوا الاطراف الى اتفاق الاطاري